[Music]
Conan O'Brien is here he's GNA be here
today
yeah
y
[Music]
YY be cool my babies okay do not tell
him I did that he is not here yet do not
this up for me he gave me the show he's
he's a hero of mine obviously so please
uh let's all forget that that happened
so Happy Thanksgiving it's Thanksgiving
which means uh all the people watching
at home you're probably watching this
surrounded by members of your
family yeah I so sorry about
that what I'm saying is there's
something special about going back to
the house you grew up in and seeing your
parents cuz the second I go back my
whole family starts acting the way we
did 15 years ago you know what I'm
talking about it's like cuz that's the
last time we were all together so every
time we get back together we all just
start putting on this
play does that make sense we're all
putting on a play a play called when
Pete was
17 does that resonate it's all the same
lines mom's going to wake me up too
early for no reason even though I have
an alarm clock that works it fing
works it works mom and I try I try to
calmly explain that to her like a
34-year-old but all that comes out is
Mom long did I here five more minutes
I'm 34 Mommy I have a
401k I can't I can't be grown at home CU
it's like theater it's like weird German
experimental theater where the kids are
being played by grown ass adults and
it's never addressed they're just like I
like how the teams are being played by
grown people it's very
sexual I just assume German theater is
very sexual they're like I am
aroused was that offensive to the
Germans everyone has the same concerns
when I go home too my dad is always like
hey drive safe on the freeway and I want
to be like you drive safe on the freeway
you're
old I don't have to wear special driving
glasses and I know how to operate the
blinker but all I say is thanks Dad and
he slips me 20 bucks which I take I take
the 20 why I'm grown I have cash I
should give him 20 he still has dial up
internet but it's a play it's a play
it's a play and everybody knows their
part that's why it's always so awkward
to bring a girlfriend home anytime I've
brought a girlfriend home for
Thanksgiving it's weird to everyone
suddenly there's just this new girl
that's just improvising
lines the play has been the same for 34
season it's and it's like this is Taff
hey y'all shut
up St those aren't the lines that's
everybody and it's extra confusing to
her because I'm playing both the role of
a 17-year-old me and her 34y old
boyfriend that's confusing I'm like Mom
I don't want fish I don't want fish cuz
it tastes fishy I told you I told you I
told you it smells bad tastes like it
smell then I turned to my girlfriend
like you want to in my race car bed
bed vroom vroom vroom
bab that's a confusing
day and your parents treat you like a
teenager I think because that's the last
time they really knew you on a
day-to-day basis you know what I mean
they know you have this big adult life
but they weren't there for any of that
you just went off when you were 18 like
Bilbo
baggin and you come home and they don't
know you've been out killing
dragons and they're just trying to
relate your mom's like you're still
friends with
galum it's Gollum mom and we weren't
really friends you never
listen I wish I had my ring so I could
disappear
me too
bbo